- All right, Boogie.
So, with your Comedy Slam, which is
hilarious. I had the chance to watch it.
Whenever I'm telling people about it,
they're almost surprised that
you are, like, a funny, silly guy.
So would you describe yourself as that?
- I mean, I am.
I mean, it's funny you say that because, you
know, usually the only time that I'm seen is
during my occupation.
So it's not really about
fun and games at that point—well, for me.
I take the game seriously.
But outside of the lines, I'm a
goofy, laid-back guy.
So, I enjoy comedy,
I enjoy laughing,
and I enjoy good vibes.
So, that's what I'm about.
-Now, I know
obviously you have some
hilarious guys in your special.
Tell me about them and what makes
them, you know, very special and funny guys.
- Well, you know, guys like Mike Epps,
Red Grant and Gary Owen, they've
been in the game for a long time. When
it comes to the younger guys, you know,
the Karlous Miller, and not necessarily
young in age, but just young in the game.
00:01:02,960 --> 00:01:06,320
You know, they bring that next
generation of funny, which,
I always want that combination.
I want some of the older, OG guys
in the game and the new and up-and-coming.
So that's kinda how I go about it.
- I hear that you are also
a bit of a jokester.
Would you say that's true?
- Yeah.
I like to joke a lot actually, so.
- OK,
so I'm putting you on the spot with this.
I'm not asking you to tell me what the
exact joke is, but give me the gist,
OK?
I'm gonna name an NBA player, and you tell
me if you were making a joke about them,
what it would be along the lines of,
OK?
- Oh, come on!
- If we're doing comedy, DeMarcus,
we’re doing comedy.
- Ohhh, naw,
that's crazy.
- Are you ready?
- Yeah, shoot.
- It's only two or three. OK.
- All right, all right.
- John Wall.
- The USA, the USA picture.
- [Laughing] And I assume you joke
about that a lot with him.
- Yes.
- OK.
Anthony Davis.
- The unibrow, obviously.
- [Laughing] OK.
LeBron James.
- I mean, the typical hair jokes about Bron.
So—
- [Laughing] OK.
Last one.
- OK.
- Steph Curry.
- That mouthpiece, man.
I feel bad for it.
- Always hanging out, always hanging out.
- Just, yeah.
- Shifting gears a little bit,
I think you saw that I spoke
to Mikey Williams a couple
weeks ago about HBCUs and the
possibility of him going to an HBCU.
And you are a player that
he specifically mentioned as
somebody who reached out to him
in support and encouragement.
Tell me about that
conversation with Mikey.
- You know, I basically sent him a
message saying, “You know, you got a chance
to, you know, change sports as a
whole, start a trend that should
have already, you know, happened.”
You know, looking back
on it now, I wish I had that
opportunity to, you know,
do it the right way,
in my opinion. The attention, the
energy that a kid like Mikey
could take to any HBCU would,
like I said, change the, you know,
face of college sports.
I had a chance to be on campus at Howard,
and I guess it was a time where, you
know, people may have been switching
classes, whatever the case may be.
And it was just like—I was, like, in awe
of, like, how many, like, blacks.
I've never seen it in my life.
- Yeah.
- And I was just in awe.
So, with that being said, I'm like, “Man.”
Like, even in that moment, I'm like,
“Damn, I should've, you know, I should've came
to Howard,” or whatever the case may be.
- Obviously anybody who has followed your
career knows that you went to Kentucky.
So I guess my question is
what has caused the change?
Meaning, what do you understand
now that maybe you didn't
understand then?
- The business.
And it's sad to say, but even
college, it's a business.
You know, obviously the athletes don't
benefit from it, but everything around
it is a business, and it's a reason they
want those kids at the school that could
easily be at HBCU with that same type of
attention, with that same type of income.
And,
and it’s well-deserved.
- It's gonna be really
interesting to see,
and I think that it gives us a lot
of pride and I think hope to know that the
younger generation is looking to do that
and the steps that
they're taking right now.
So, I totally agree.
- Absolutely.
- I want you to put on your analyst
hat. Give me your predictions.
- OK.
- Who's winning the championship this year?
- I don't know.
I got asked this question earlier.
I honestly don't know.
If it was the regular
season, it was playing out,
you know, the way it was, I think the
Lakers. But with the current situation
and everything that's into play,
I mean, all it takes is a guy to test
positive, and it changes a whole series.
Everybody has the same opportunity.
So you can't say it's,
this is a, you know, “championship,
put it to the side,” because that's not true.
So, but it is teams that now have
a chance that didn't have one before.
I'll be tuned in, to say the
least, because I'm excited.
I feel like it's gonna be a team
that nobody expects.
- What is it gonna be like
playing without fans?
Like, what do you think the
guys are thinking right now?
What can you not say on the court
because everybody might hear it?
- The words will be very limited
at this point.
- OK, last one for you just cuz
I’m curious:
What percentage of stuff said on the court
can't be heard?
Is it 90 percent?
Is it 85?
Like, what percentage of stuff
is like, “This cannot be said”?
- I’d say about—oh, that cannot be said?
- Cannot be said
- And is actually being said on the court?
- Yeah, like in a normal game, right?
- I’d say about 70 percent.
- 70 percent?
- Yeah.
- OK,
so we're gonna get 30 percent of what
it's actually like on the court?
No, I think you're gonna get
a whole 70 percent. What I'm saying,
it's about a good 70 percent that
the people cannot hear.
- Yeah, OK.
- So you hearin’ about 30 percent on
the nightly. A good 70 is
being, you know, blocked out or whatever.
But with the court being empty, yeah.
- No, absolutely.
Well, I'm sure hearing everything
will absolutely be comedy.
So it's gonna be very
fitting for this interview.
- For sure.
- You were a blast. Like I said,
everybody should watch the comedy special.
It is available now exclusively
on Amazon video on demand.
And thank you so much for your time.
- All right, thank you.